Janet Jackson calls the police to check  on her one-year-old son with with some  Amana et's Kevin Frazier reached out to  Janet's brother Randy Jackson who says  the 51 year old singer contacted  authorities on Saturday after a nanny  who was helping her estranged husband  care for their son reached out to her  stating she became frightened by with  Psalms behavior which she believed to be  aggressive we spoke to Randy who claimed  the nanny was terrified by his behavior  and locked herself in a bathroom so she  could contact Janet a watch commander  with the Malibu County Sheriff's Office  confirms two et they responded to a call  around 9:50 p.m. at Nobu hotel in Malibu  to check on the welfare of Janet's only  child I thank God for him you guys he is  so healthy so beautiful so sweet so  loving such a happy baby Jackson split  from all mana in April of 2017 just  three months after giving birth to their  son we are in court and the rest is in  God's hands